we're kicking off the year with CNN's  Don Lemon we're at the point in here at  CNN where we realize that I'm click  think for example about black lives  matter you taking a selfie right now is  that a little sweat am I making you  nervous and it's you know reform on gun  control and you even talk like this it's  a specific where you have to hurts or  for you in mobile and you're taking  you're taking naps in that is your  office right there I say let's you  blanket so you do take that just before  you just before we hooked up on skype  yeah we connected on skype go back and  look at the whole thing and what I said  you're like wait a minute that's not  what happened at all well done I don't  have that kind of time to listen to  context I think you had I think 48 wings  on a plane  no I often find that the people who are  supposed to be the most tolerant are the  least because they they never consider  that they in fact may not be